nein es ist so oh peace Leute was geht
ab ich bin's Marvin ich bin's Kelvin und
heute machen wir eine Wettessen
Challenge denn
du musst dann wieder weiter reden wir
wollen heute essen
denn wir haben heute bei einem
kebabladen in Köln bestellt
und mache jetzt im Bett Essen Challenge
[Musik]
du isst doch schon die ganze Zeit nichts
geht über
krass
Verpackung
liebes gar nichts mehr drin bleibt
[Musik]
wir schaffen dies dass sie dabei reden
rüber auf die eine Seite und Schaufel
erstmal den kompletten Reis rein
ich esse den Salat
machen
[Musik]
egal
was hast du mir gar nichts gesagt
sieht aus als wärst du vorne ne
warum wir euch fragt warum das Single
sind wegen genau so solche Videos dicker
Geld in dating App investieren
Investition in die Zukunft
[Musik]
anders damit andere
aktuell bin ich in Istanbul für eine
Woche schmeckt gut aber Pflanzen besser
ja du kannst nichts vergleichen aber
schmeckt lecker
[Musik]
ich kann mir
Spaß ich kann
[Musik]
Brot auch aufessen ne
ah klar die ganze Zeit Brot
natürlich gesagt
schneller als wenn man schnell ist ähm
nein
natürlich ist man schneller wenn man
schneller ist
trotzdem
[Musik]
ich kann doch alles einfach direkt
runterschlucken aber ist ja scheiße ich
kaufe halt die ganze Zeit noch weißt du
[Musik]
einen Daumen hoch da meistens
testet so 200 Millionen privat an der
Jets
wir essen noch
essen kann
[Musik]
ich habe schon wieder nicht verstanden
warum egal
stimmt doch einfach runter
weil wir kriegen safe Verstopfung davon
weil so viel Brot ist
mit drin
wir schauen uns jetzt hier
ganz genau darauf geachtet gesehen
dein Arsch wird Arschloch wird so
brennen Bruder heute Nacht
ein bisschen Gemüse
wisst ihr was das schlimmste ist luca
hat sich noch zweiten Teller bestellt
wir sind auch essen leicht ja ich muss
auf meine Kalorien kommen 4000 hast du
noch Hunger bisschen
wieso bin ich dann Fett
genau ich schwöre ich hatte scharfe Soße
Digger sonst kippe ich jetzt tot um
noch da Ciao Leute was geht ab
ich bin's Marvin ich bin's Kevin danke
für das Video luca ist der Sieger